okay so I have a puzzle for you we got a
hexagon here and I want to know how many
ways can you draw in three
non-intersection diagonals of the
hexagon to split it up into four
triangles so here's an example and we're
going to count rotations as different so
this is not going to be the same as say
this one the question is how many ways
are there in total the answer is 14 so
we can think about this one we get six
rotations of this
one then we also have this one where we
have a little zigzag and again this has
six rotations and the remaining two are
triangles our little equilateral
triangle ones so this gives 14 ways in
total does beg the question what about
if we use a pentagon for example uh we
want to look one level simpler so this
time instead of splitting into four
triangles with three lines I'm going to
split it into three triangles with two
lines and hopefully you believe me that
this is one way and that the other ways
are all going to be rotations of this so
there are five ways in total okay going
back level simpler Square well there are
going to be two of these now we use one
line to split into two triangles so
there are two ways a triangle we use no
lines to split it into one triangle and
there's one way of doing that and I'm
even going to say a 2d shape and we're
going to split it into no triangles and
we're going to say there's one way of
doing that as well so we've got our
little pattern here one one 2 5
14 got another problem for you now um
now this is going to talk about
something called binary trees so binary
trees we start at a node and at each
point you can either choose to do
nothing or split it so here this is
called a binary tree of order three
because down here we've got three nodes
at the bottom now another binary tree of
order three might look like this and in
fact these are these are the only two
binary trees of order three how many
binary trees do we think there are of
order four well start drawing them we've
got one like this we can then maybe do
that oh and we can reflect this one now
so then we get this and we can also
reflect this one oh and actually there
is one more we can get so I'm fairly
confident these are all of them there
are five for completeness
sake of order two there is precisely one
and of order one there is also just one
so again we've got one one 2 five do you
want have a guess at how many binary
trees of order five there are there are
actually 14 binary trees of order
five so the pattern is 1 1 2 5 14 H
which is the same as this one so this
third problem involves something called
got to get the German pronunciation
right de words named after the
mathematician de pronounced with a long
ey sound in the middle so de words are
made up of the same number of x's and
y's but there's a rule um at no point in
the word can you have had more y's than
X's before that point so for example
something like x x y y is allowed
something like X Y YX is not allowed
because at this point if we cut it off
here there are two y's and only one X's
so the number of x's must be greater
than or equal to the number of y's at
all points in a sequ quence so how many
de words are there for certain lengths
well if we have none of each I guess
that there's one one way of having the
empty de word I just draw a box to
symbolize that is here if we have one x
one y it has to be X then y because if
it's y than x then we've got more y's
than X's what about if we have two of
each well we can have XX y y we could
also have X Y X Y we can't have x y y X
as I've said and it's going to have to
start with an x if it starts with a y
then we failed at the first step now
what about with three of each so we can
have x x x y y y we could have x x y x y
y we could also actually have x x y y x
y how about x y x x y y and then we can
alternate we can have X Y X Y X Y okay
these are all the Deep words with 3 x's
and three y's now do you want try
guessing how many deep words there are
with four x's and four y's it's 14 so
we've got this one one 2 54 patent again
so there must be something special about
these numbers and these actually have a
special name they're called the Catalan
[Music]
numbers but first I want to look into
why these problems are all the same um
because we can actually show it um in a
really cool way so I'm going to draw in
the rest of these pentagons just so that
we can use the pentagons as an example
so what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to label some of the edges of the
pentagons and these edges are going to
form my nodes so they're going to form
these bits at the bottom of the binary
tree it's going to become clear soon and
then actually we've got some interior
nodes here as well so let's draw these
in and these are going to be within the
triangles this currently might seem a
bit confusing however let's now join up
the lines going step by step so at this
point we can see we've got one interior
node we can only go through edges and if
you imagine this uncoiling we're going
to end up with this CU we've still got
our dots in exactly the same place and
our end points in exactly the same place
so these two represent the same thing
similarly if we get this one okay
uncoiled this one's going to look like
this one uncoiled
we can do this with all of them so it
makes sense that these represent the
same things in different ways which is
why we have the same pattern okay what
about these two now well for this I'm
actually going to label the little edges
between nodes and I'm going to label
them X if they go left and Y if they go
right first we go X then we have to go
through an X to get there and we have to
go through an X to get there the next
One X but we've already ticked that one
off X y take this y off to get here x
we've ticked off Y and this one is just
y so this can represent XX X Y y y which
is this code so this one first node got
to go through X then X to get there the
next node we go x y That's not ticked
off X now to get to this one x y y and
we've got y so this x x y x y y is this
code and actually all of these binary
trees represent a de word like that so
these again are different ways of
representing the same thing which is why
we end up with the same answer and that
is these Catalan numbers we need a
formula for them we like formulas in
math we like to know how we can name
these patterns um and for this I'm going
to get another bit of
paper and actually I'm going to look at
it through the de words if we have nx's
and n y y well in total that's that's
two n characters isn't it and we want to
pick which of the nend spaces are going
to be X's so in general there are two n
choose n words with nx's and N y's but
not all of these are going to be deep
words so we're going to have to work out
how we can do that let's look at an
example try x y y x this isn't a deep
word but I'm going to do a neat little
trick and I'm going to add an X before
it so why am I doing this well it kind
of makes our condition easier because
before the condition was that the number
of x's is greater than or equal to the
number of y's at any point in the
sequence adding an extra X before means
that for the last four digits to be a de
word then for the whole sequence the
number of x's needs to be strictly
greater than the number of y's so we're
making this condition slightly more
specific and actually the definition for
here of this criteria is it's dominating
now there's a really cool trick you can
do here because we're going to cycle
this round through all the Cycles so
we've got x x y YX going to move this x
to the beginning so we'll have x x this
x goes here this y goes here y goes
there and finally x y y x x so we've got
five different cycles of our original
word and the co thing is that exactly
one of them has this property um in this
case it is this one so this one doesn't
because if you think at this point we've
got 2 X's two y's so they're equal so we
don't have that greater than condition
but this is the case where precisely one
of them is dominating hasard its
property and it's always going to be the
case that of these Cycles exactly one of
them is dominating and then we can get
rid of our actual X and from this we
know because it's the same condition
that well one over n + 1 of the possible
arrangements are deep words so this
means that our formula for the catalon
numbers is 1 / n + 1 * 2 N chose n
wellow there's still more you can say I
could sit here and talk for about an
hour about Catalan numbers but there is
I think one final thing that I'm going
to bring up um those of you who are
interested there are iterative formulas
you can find out about ways to relate CN
to cn+ 1 but this can also be written as
2 N choose n minus 2 N choose n minus
one whenever I see something like this
with um choose notation something
combinatorial I think Pascal's triangle
where is this in Pascal's triangle um
and this is where it becomes cool so
unfortunately my friends have been
subjected to so many Pascal's triangles
talks I think I gave my first when I was
about 12 fun this place I've told a
friend about Pascal's triangle is when
we were climbing a mountain um I had it
written out on my hand so that I could
explain what was going on um and she
actually enjoyed it she asked for it
that time so if you ever want a Pascal's
triangle talk there's never a time when
I am not ready okay running out of space
slightly but this will do the question
is where do the Catalan numbers appear
in Pascal's triangle and this little
minus sign is the key um cuz they
actually appear this column and
subtracting this column so 1 - 0 is our
first one 2 - 1 is our second one 6 - 4
gives the two this gives the five and to
finally finish off 17 - 56 it is 14 yes
so that is the Catalan
numbers here are the first 30 Catalan
numbers you can see they
escalate now if expanding your mind is
something you'd like to do well
brilliant.org is the place to do it this
is an absolute smallus Board of courses
quizzes and curated content it's all
interactive very clever it's designed to
make you
smarter whether it's mathematics
computer science chemistry physics you
name it they've got you covered it's fun
it's smart it's created by people who
know their stuff I've recently started
checking out these little bonus puzzles
I really like them have a look at this
if you keep stacking these circles
forever will the blue or yellow area be
greater or will they be the
same I've been thinking about it and now
I'm about to find out if I was right
this is a great place to hang out just
to flex your brain cells you can do a
free 30-day trial with brilliant you can
also get 20% off their full premium
service by going to brilliant.org snum
file I'll put a link in the video
description so you can click right on
that if you like not entirely sure what
these guys are doing but all right oh
and by the way you can also give
brilliant as a gift a nice present for
that Learner in your life perhaps our
thanks to brilliant for supporting
number
far so in particular like problems where
I have end things and I want to choose K
of them how many different ways can I do
that and it turns out that Pascal's
triangle this really like childlike
adding game as it seems to be actually
encodes n choose K so if I have N Things
in particular let's say I have four
things